[Music]
REO maybe super but even he must get
bored hurtling the same goo bus and
falling off the same cliffs over and
over
fortunately a new artificial
intelligence algorithm for what's called
procedural content generation can
endlessly produce new levels and make
sure they meet certain criteria video
games such as no man's sky use
procedural content generation to
automatically generate up to 18
quintillion unique planets for players
exploring the galaxy a daunting task for
any human designer but programmers still
need to handcraft the rules that tell
the computer how to create such content
game levels are particularly tricky to
generate because small changes can make
them unplayable a stray wall can seal
off a critical passage but machine
learning and AI technique by which
computers learn from many examples as
generated levels for several games
including Super Mario Brothers Starcraft
2 and The Legend of Zelda in this
example of an AI making Mario levels
there are two phases and the first a
generative adversarial Network learns
through trial and error to transform
strings of numbers into levels
indistinguishable from human created
levels a second phase then helps find
number strings that lead to levels that
are not just realistic
but that fit certain requirements such
as having a lot of enemies for jumps
giving researchers precise control over
difficulty the researchers believe their
approach would work for other games too
another method uses adversarial networks
to produce new maps for do the classic
first-person shooter the algorithm
creates new maps that match human
creating ones visually and on certain
higher-level features such as the
balance of large and small rooms
procedural content generation doesn't
just save designers time and mario from
tedium could also help improve video
games allowing games to adapt to players
on the fly so each level is not too hard
not too easy
just super
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]